monsieur le député je vais pas tourner
autour du pot on a l'impression c'est ce
que pensent beaucoup de français
qu'après avoir foiré les masques après
avoir foiré les tests le gouvernement a
foiré dans un premier temps la
vaccination la parole à la défense
oui merci la bonne soirée et merci pour
cette invitation d'abord aux foires et
les masses foire et les tests on
pourrait en rediscuter à l'issue de
cette mission avait parlant de la
vaccination la vaccination voilà moi ce
que je veux dire dans un premier temps
c'est que ce calendrier vaccinal qui est
mise en place la actuellement depuis
début janvier c'est celui qui a été
actée novo fin novembre début décembre
il a été acté par les médecins des
associations de patients
il était présenté à l'assemblée
nationale et à cette époque là tout le
monde l'a validé en tant que tel et nous
sommes en train de le mettre en place
tel qu'il est avec quand même un
impératif c'est celui que nous avons un
nombre de doses limites et comme tous
les autres pays en europe à ce sont des
accords européens on y reviendra
probablement là dessus donc partant ce
principe là nous avons priorisé les
personnes les plus fragiles et nous
mettons en place
effectivement il y a un temps de mise en
place qui est celui du consentement j'en
ai fait un certain nombre dans l'ehpad
de ma commune principal dans ma ville
puisque je continue mon activité
s'ils ont effectivement les patients
âgés effectivement aussi il ya une
accélération qui se fait actuellement
en rabattant la phase 2 sur la phase une
pour permettre aux personnes de plus de
75 ans d'être prioritaires aussi mais je
rappelle que les personnes de plus de 15
ans ces cinq millions de personnes en
france
nous n'avions pas jusqu'à lors le nombre
de doses pour me dire que c'était prévu
quand on a affaire à quelque chose qui
pourrit la vie alors pas seulement la
france de l'europe entière du monde
entier on s'attend à ce que vraiment
vous mettiez le paquet au début et au
bout d'une journée on apprend qu'il ya à
peine quelques dizaines à la garçonne
qui avait mis d'accord parce que le
président de la république un peu
souffler dans les bronches de monsieur
verrons un peu taper sur la table et on
a peu augmenté la cadence mais comment
vous expliquez même d'un point de vue
psychologique que face à un problème
pareil on ne met pas la gomme
immédiatement ensuite je l'entends le
pôle professeurs seront là mais on la
met la gomme comme vous dites mais avec
une priorisation sur ces personnes
fragile c'est beaucoup plus long mais il
faut savoir que 1 % les pâtes les
personnes qui sont en ehpad 6 1% de la
population en france c'est 35 % la
mortalité
un moment donné il fallait prioriser des
gens on a priorisé ces personnes là
c'est plus long à mettre en place
effective et ça va vraiment monter en
puissance
ben regarde et on est déjà à quarante
cinq mille mais ça je prends toujours
cet exemple là quand vous avez en vous
donne 100 euros pour un mois vous pouvez
dépenser sur le premier jour vous pouvez
les dépenses et sur un mois à la fin du
mois ce sera toujours pareil c'est ce
qui se passe en allemagne il fermer un
certain nombre de sang tout parce qu'ils
n'ont plus de doses
on a un nombre limité de données
heureusement donc vous êtes prêt à
revenir nous en parler à répondre de ce
que vous venez de nous dire à des
prochaines semaines
ici il y aura sera maîtresse en euros il
y aura un effet de suivi un professeur
ce vague infectiologues à la pitié
salpêtrière où l'irs réagir non merci
pour la promotion je suis pas encore
professeur mes docteurs ça ira tout seul
aussi quand on peut faire plus de jeu
les députés mais également mon confrère
ce que vous avez oublié de dire c'est
que il ya une pression de la part des
soignants parce que les soignants nous
étions prévu beaucoup plus tard oui et
qu' il était quand même inadmissible
moi même étant infectiologues et donc en
première ligne dans un département des
maladies infectieuses à la pitié
salpêtrière
heureusement qu'il eut cette pression a
que très vite on a fait marche arrière
on a dit les soignants alors un à dix
après 50 ans moi je pense que ça devrait
être
on n'aurait pas donné de limite d'âge et
grâce à cette décision fait rouler à
fait moi même je veux lire j'ai été vexé
les ya trois jours dans mon service donc
voila mais il voit monsieur le député
maire jérôme coumet
alors on est passé juste jolie là-dessus
effectué on est passé de 69 je demandais
si j'étais vaccinées soit non mais je
vais vous le dire elle est passée de 65
ans à 50 ans ou facteurs de risque et
même dans l'ehpad où j'irai vacciner et
où je me ferai vacciner demain la
réponse également pour les soignants qui
n'ont pas spécialement de facteurs de
risque mais sur lesquels il reste des
doses parce que comme vous savez on a
cinq doses par flacon voir 5,6 même donc
on a quelquefois des doses qui reste
donc on peut effectivement vaccinés ceux
qui le souhaitent alors pour finir sur
ce début de campagne de vaccination
danny forster qui est directeur adjoint
d'un ehpad dans le var alors on a ciblé
les populations les plus fragiles
d'ailleurs ce qui peut se comprendre
sauf que si j'ai bien compris dans votre
ehpad ça se passe pas quand même très
bien c'est à dire qu'il ya un nombre
minimal de patients qui ont été en fait
de résident dans votre cas qui ont été
vaccinés quand ça se fait comme il a
justement un dit c'est que c'est vrai
qu'on doit recueillir le consentement et
ça prend du temps c'est pas une décision
prise de manière hâtive
il faut justement convaincre
de manière avec les médecins
coordinateurs et les médecins traitants
les résidents et les familles si vous
restez pas le bon timing parce que
c'était noël et nouvel an et puis dans
les ehpad et avais pas envie de penser à
autre chose là on parle que de qovu et
donc c'est vrai que voilà on a commencé
à vraiment requiert le consentement
depuis vraiment la semaine dernière et
c'est vrai que beaucoup de résidents et
m des familles sont réticents parce que
je sens que ça veut dire qu'elle refuse
c'est finalement kenzy c'est vrai que ce
ne soit l'heureux oui leur fille puis
c'est vrai qu'ils avaient pas beaucoup
de pédagogie de transparence sur ce
vaccin quand même de la part du
gouvernement ça a commencé en tout cas
des vidéos de professeur alain fischer
mais ça a pris du temps à envoyer
est-ce que c'est pas trop compliqué d'un
point de vue bureaucratique en entend
beaucoup cet argument que ça ralentit
beaucoup la cadence non il ya une
polémique comme quoi il fallait attendre
cinq jours ça y est totalement fausse et
lui refasse les médecins qui ont dit ça
sur les plates on m'a lu le protocole le
protocole c'est une bonne base de
travail lorsqu'on a invité aujourd'hui
ce soir que des médecins fiable pour
nous distinguer des autres émissions
c'est maintenant mais aussi d'inviter
notre mission voilà il faut continuer
parce qu'on a beaucoup de personnes qui
parlent je trouve deux des médecins des
avocats ou même des d'autres personnes
qui parlent au sujet du coc vite mais en
fait ils ne connaissent rien et ça
alimente justement ces théories de
complot par fait circuler sur les cinq
jours de désistement ça n'existe pas ça
n'a jamais existé incroyable note de
charme on a eu chaud mais on a entendu
sa préparation de la dose en fait
simplement bon premières informations
premier scoop content de décongeler de
préparer at war je vous prends un
exemple très concret j'ai fait mes
derniers un consentement hier pour mes
patients on vaccine de demain enfin
pardon est ce que je pense qu'il vaut
mieux quand même dire la vérité parce
que quand on nous paie démarrage ont le
look se sont tout le monde en est
conscient et même le président la
république que même en était conscient
et vous a mis un coup de pied au
derrière pour accélérer maintenant que
vous nous expliquer ces cinq jours de
consentement n'ont jamais existé ne dit
pas ça parce que sur les plateaux télé
même les membres de voix de majorité
nous ont expliqué pendant des sous des
jours et des jours qui avaient cinq
jours de consentement nous avons changé
les règles non mais soit vous avez
changé
c'est normal attendez attendez parce que
là c'est important moi je veux qu'on
existe le député sanaa
franchement ça n'a jamais existé
d'accord il ya une lecture qui a été est
peut-être la république a dit qu'il
fallait mais faire un ces cinq jours de
consentement qui leur est agrégé des
buts et j'ai vu gérard lâcher leur
profond chez celles actuellement est un
document et 93 96 pages et il disait
voilà je vais lisible c'est trop long ou
désisté ramener parce qu'il parlait des
58 pages 45 45
mais moi j'attends des visées chacun
attend je suis prédisait lui dirai 58 je
lui disais 58 j'avais twitté 50 ça
continuait saluant son gré parce qu'ils
favorisaient la polémique est née parce
que ce fascicule là il était pour les
directeurs d'ehpad et pour les soignants
n'est absolument pas pour les parents de
cédric nous n'avons jamais eu cinq jours
de délai mais ce ne sont pas les
patients fin des condamnés aux personnes
qui doit venir les 45 pages du new york
et d'imaginer on a entendu ça je m'y
attendais sur les plateaux d'occident ça
que je suis demandé à enlever les cinq
jours de délai donc n'ai même pas réussi
à expliquer aux médecins qui avait pas
cinq jours de délai enfin on l'a pas
inventé les cinq jours de délai de
consentement d'où est ce que ça serait
revenu alors non je pense qu'il ya eu il
ya eu il ya eu une méprise entre le fait
de dire il nous faut cinq jours pour
préparer les doses
j'aime mes fans et pour commander le fc
c'était marqué dans le fascicule
français on appelle fascicule non non on
va dire oui mais moi je sais ça c'est
monsieur moreau physique me dis que ça
n'existe pas le débat est enchaînée à
cette démarche n'aurait salah moins vrai
qu'on a entendu ça pendant une semaine
sur tous les plateaux moins sérieux que
le nôtre